hi I'm Alex I'm a tasty producer and
today I'm gonna show you how I make
viral food videos so this banana bread
Bottom cheesecake is my all-time
favorite video for one I have a love of
cheesecake and a love of banana bread so
it just kind of made sense to pair the
two together I think this video went
viral because it was something that
hadn't actually been done before and I
really just tried to make something new
and interesting and something that
people would just say like wow how did I
not think of that before they think
separating the two and then recombining
them in a new way is what really made
this video work so well so I really
worked hard to try to get the two
distinct layers you get the classic
banana bread bottom and then the creamy
luxurious cheesecake on top and that
made a really cool visual at the end you
had the moment of pouring the cheesecake
batter onto the banana bread itself and
of course the caramel drizzle I mean
like that just pushed this over the top
I mean who doesn't want a caramel
drizzle on either their cheesecake or
their banana bread and I'll just kind of
work together you know this next video
for chicken parm lasagna was actually my
third video I've ever done that I had a
ton of crazy ideas that I just wanted to
get out into the world and this was one
of them
I remember for this specific video I
actually was talking to Andrew ill Nikki
I remember just being like what do you
think about like a chicken lasagna where
you just layered chicken instead of
noodles it's like cheese in between and
he was like that's really weird
so Andrew thought it was weird but I
still thought that there was something
there so I tried to develop the recipe a
little in my mind and realized that the
classic flavors of lasagna and the
classic flavors of chicken parm overlap
you know you've got the marinara the
mozzarella the parmesan and the tomato
sauce or I said marinara
this video wasn't actually a recipe at
all it was just kind of skinning a
watermelon and seeing you know how
people react to it which was kind of
different than anything we had really
done before on tasty normally my job
entails you know coming up with a recipe
coming into the office going through
testing it and developing that recipe
shooting that recipe and then going off
and editing my own videos it's funny
because cooking at home is so so
different than making a tasty video
there's so many different factors that
you have to pay attention to you know
the recipe has to work it has to look
good of course because we're making it
into a video for you to enjoy hopefully
it's something new and exciting that
someone hasn't seen before so that they
want to know Sharon so that it does go
viral as a video so there's all these
different elements that actually go into
making one minute to two-minute video
and I wanted to definitely get the
reaction because like why else would you
do something like this
alright so Ali go now this is actually
something I used to eat as a kid my mom
would make it but I had no idea what it
was it was just like super cheesy
potatoes and I don't know if there's any
better combination than that but I saw
it bring me video of someone in France
making it at a restaurant and I realized
that it was like the coolest process to
see like tons of cheese go into these
potatoes and then stretching it up with
a big paddle and it was also something I
knew I could make at home because my mom
had made it so many times this was so
delicious I literally could have eaten
the whole pot but I'm also very lactose
intolerant so I've always had a love of
cooking and a love of food I remember
growing up like my siblings always
wanted to watch cartoons and I was
sitting watching the Food Network the
joy that I felt in the kitchen was
something that I couldn't get anywhere
and I just always knew I wanted to be
surrounded by food and immersed in
cooking but I ended up going off to
college I started to study science and
kind of just was doing what I thought I
was supposed to be doing but through
college I kind of started to miss you
know being really involved in cooking
and in food so I actually ended up
starting a health and food blog which is
funny because I couldn't be making
anything more different here at tasty
but now I'm making crazy things like
this Neapolitan cake roll and I had a
lot of fun doing my food blog but I was
still studying and thinking I was going
to go into a medical profession but it's
literally like two weeks before I
graduated from college I decided I just
wanted to give it a shot and I didn't
quite know where I belonged
but I knew I wanted to be in the food
industry so I packed up and I moved to
Sweden which was crazy I know
but I am a little bit of a wild soul so
I was in Sweden I started working as a
food stylist for a cookbook author Mia
and I got really into that and it was
super fun and it was kind of my first
glimpse of a profession that I loved in
the food industry that I could see
myself pursuing I remember one of the
first times I was picking with me
kitchen and Sweden and she left me to
make a whole recipe on my own and I was
so nervous I kept going up to her and
asking her questions like is this right
is this right and she looked at me and
said you can do it's fine
stop asking any questions and that was
the first time I kind of felt like whoa
like she trusts me to do this on my own
and I did it tasted great it looked
great and I just felt like that was a
turning point for me and if my story can
inspire anybody to take a chance on
their own dreams
you know maybe moving to Sweden is not
the most realistic but you don't have to
move to Sweden to invest in your own
trainings you can do it all right
[Music]
what if I don't got these things down I
don't know
[Music]
you